[موسيقى]
في مثل هذا اليوم وعند الخامسه صباحا
بتوقيت كيف اهتزت العديد من المدن
الاوكرانيه جراء القصف الروسي وتاكد
العالم من انطلاق ما اسماه الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه
في اوكرانيا ما هي الى ساعات حتى تم اعلان
سيطره القوات الروسيه القادمه من الجهه
الشماليه على محطه تشرنوبيل النوويه اما
جنوبا فمدينه خرسون كانت اولى المدن التي
وقعت في قبضه الجيش الروسي بعدها بيوم
واحد سقطت مدينه زاكوريا المتاخمه اما في
التاسع من شهر مارس اذار صدم العالم من
صور استهداف القوات الروسيه لمستشفى
الاطفال في ماريوبول والذي اوقع عددا من
القتلى والجرحى المدنيين
هو الاخر كان عنوان الصحفي بعدما استهدفته
الطائرات المقاتله الروسيه مما ادى الى
قتل العشرات وجرح مئات المدنيين الذين
اختباوا في الداخل
في مطلع شهر ابريل نيسان دخلت القوات
الاوكرانيه الى مدينه واكتشفت ما سمي
لاحقا بمجزره
لكن تاريخ الرابع عشر من ذات شهر كان نقطه
تحول في اخبار الغزو الروسي عندما غرق
التراد الروسي موسكوبا في البحر الاسود
دون ان يتضح من المسؤول عن الحادث
في الحادي والعشرين من ايلول نيسان اعلن
الرئيس الروسي عن سقوط ماريوبول وحصار
مصنع ازوفيستال الذي كان ياوي مئات الجنود
والمدنيين الاوكرانيين اما في نهايه الشهر
استهدفت صواريخ الروسيه القادمه بشبه
جزيره القرم مطار اوديسا في مطلع شهر
يوليو انسحبت القوات الاوكرانيه من مدينه
ليسي تشانس كاليستراتيجيه في دومباس
وبعدها بيومين تبادلت القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه القصف في محيط محطه زابوريجيا
للطاقه قبل ان يحذر الرئيس فلادي من خطر
وقوع كارثه نوويه يعلن بعضها الرئيس
الاوكراني بايام عن تحرير مدينه ايسيوم
الاستراتيجيه من قبضه الجيش الروسي حينها
كانت موسكو قد اعلنت عن التعبئه الجزئيه
لجنود الاحتياط قبل ان تنظم سته لضم اربع
مناطق اوكرانيه خاضعه لسيطرتها في الشهر
نفسه اتهم الغرب موسكو بتفجير انابيب نورت
ستريم فيما نفث هذه الاخيره قبل ان تنشر
تقارير صحفيه امريكيه عن تورط واشنطن في
العمليه
في اكتوبر تشرين الاول تفاجا الجميع ببث
صور الانفجار الذي دمر جزئيا جسر القرن
الرابط بين روسيا وشبه الجزيره تتابعت
المفاجاه بعد اعلان الجيش الروسي انسحابهم
من مدينه خرطسون اما دوليا وبعد جدل كبير
وافقت كل من واشنطن عن تزويد كييف بدبابات
ثقيله لمساعدتها على تغيير المعطيات
الميدانيه معطيات الاسبقيه فيها حاليا
لمجموعه فاغنر الخاصه شرقا والتي سيطرت
على بلده سوليدار القريبه من مدينه باخموت
التي يحتدم فيها القتال منذ اشهر